I spend 100 hours researching the
wackiest theories in one piece like the
theory that this dude is actually
Luffy's mother Luffy might die at the
end of one piece but here's an absurd
sounding theory that might actually make
sense the first ever rival devil fruit
user that Luffy fought in the story was
buggy the clown all the way back at the
beginning of One Piece buggy who ate the
chop chop fruit was revealed to have
known Luffy's Mentor Shanks as a child
and even served alongside him as a cabin
boy on Goldie Roger the pirate King's
ship throughout the entire series as
Luffy has fought tooth and nail to get
stronger buggy has been failing upwards
after Luffy teamed up with him to break
out of the prison imple down buggy was
named a warlord of the Sea by the world
government and now he's even become an
emperor of the sea but if buggy keeps
accidentally stumbling into higher and
higher positions in the pirate world
there's only one more place to go after
being called a yonko that's right even
even though Luffy will be the one to
deserve the title of pirate king the
most is it possible that the world will
recognize buggy as the pirate king first
however in all my research that theory
doesn't even come close to the craziest
that's right there are 10 more theories
even crazier than buggy becoming pirate
king now this next one deals with who
had Luffy's gomogomonomi before Luffy
did lots of people long assumed that it
must have been Roger after all Roger
shares a dream with Luffy he was the
original owner of the straw hat and has
a really similar personality to Luffy so
it would only make sense if Roger had
the gomugomonomi as well but this Theory
says that it's not Roger after all but
porquez D roosh who previously had the
rubber fruit and for those of you who
need a reminder Rouge is Luffy's brother
Ace's mother so she's noticeable for
having been pregnant with AIDS for two
years before giving finally birth to him
since the government was rounding up any
baby that could have been Roger's
Offspring she somehow kept Ace in her
womb for 15 extra months how is this
possible well according to this Theory
she did it because she had a really
stretchy uterus I guess now I know that
Oda series isn't exactly scientifically
over accurate especially when it comes
to the medical field but this one seems
like a stretch in more than one way but
moving on from this we all know that
Goda is a master of foreshadowing
therefore he'd never put anything in his
series that wasn't relevant so what was
the Davey back fight Arc all about where
the straw hats competed with foxy on
Long ring Long Long Islands pits and
arcs so disliked by some fans that some
people mistakenly think that it's a
fillery I use is to think that honestly
but nope this is an actual Canon manga
Arc so will Davey backfights become
important again at some points well some
people think that it will come back in a
big way when the straw hats finally go
head to head with not Shanks but the
Blackbeard Pirates now every one-piece
theorist out there has their own dream
matchup of which starhad will fight with
which Blackbeard Pirate so imagine the
god-tier trolling that Oda could pull
when Marshall the teach challenges Luffy
to this high stakes ridiculous game
definitely more ridiculous than this
next one cyborg Frankie the shipwright
of the straw hats built a Thousand Sunny
after The Old Ship the going Mary
finally had to be retired after being
terribly damaged in many many voyages
but before he built this ship it was
revealed that Frankie had hidden the
blueprints to the ancient weapon pluton
an all-powerful warship for decades he
even went so far as to burn the
blueprints to protect them from ever
falling into the hands of the world's
governments but with his technological
genius what if he actually transferred
parts of the designs into his Dream Ship
could the Thousand Sunny be hiding some
crazy Weaponry is Oda finally going to
give us the ship to ship combat that
we've always been waiting for okay now
these next three theories are all
related and they deal with one of the
most theorized about powers in all of
One Piece in dressrosa Don Quixote
Flamingo revealed the secret hidden
power of the ope opinomi the fruit used
by Trafalgar law apparently the fruit's
immortality surgery ability can
sacrifice the user's life in order to
give someone else immortality though
Flamingo wanted law to use this power on
him but thankfully Luffy saved the day
and defeated the warlord first viewers
have noticed though that a certain set
of characters always appear to be the
same age even when they appear in
flashbacks usually when we see a
flashback like 20 or so years ago we see
the younger versions of Rayleigh or GARP
or whatever other character it's kind of
always clear that they've aged since
that point however the five eldest Stars
the gorosei always appear to look
exactly the same and we can also guess
that the same is true for the secret
leader of the world's imsama so did
several previous users of the ope
opinomi sacrifice their lives to give
the rulers of the world government
eternal life and if so would it make
sense that though flamingo a Celestial
Dragon would know about just that power
and so law having this crazy power ad
all kind of begs the question who's he
going to use the immortality surgery on
oh also this video is sponsored by Zen
Market if you also want to get your
hands on any Japanese one-piece merch
like uh this super exclusive mystery
item I got recently or really anything
else that is exclusively sold in Japan
zenmarket has got you covered through
Zen Market you can bid on Yahoo auction
listings here in Japan buy stuff from
the Pokemon Center of Bandai and just
recently rauma which is the Rakuten flea
market where you can get super rare or
vintage items for Fairly cheap prices
then Market ships worldwide for a 300
Yen service fee which is just about two
dollars right now since the Yen has
recently crashed into Oblivion so really
right now is the perfect time to get
your hands on some usually pretty
expensive Japanese goods for a real
bargain price you get free parcel
consolidation and you can combine items
from different stores into one parcel
sent to your doorstep and they have a
variety of different payment and
shipping methods that you can use as
well and if you sign up right now you
get your first item with no service fee
at all I mean it would be a crime
against storytelling to introduce such
an earth-shattering power and have it
never be relevant again in the story
well one obvious person for him to use
it on would of course be Straw Hat Luffy
himself ever since the time skip law has
been Luffy's greatest Ally in the
ongoing conflict against doflamingo
kaido and big mom and while technically
the two are Rivals for the One Piece One
could definitely imagine a scenario
where Luffy's life is threatened so law
sacrifices himself to save his ally I
mean that would be absolutely
heart-wrenching and possibly the saddest
death in the entire series after all
we've spent a lot more time with law
than we ever did with someone like Ace
or whitebeards what do you think after
all the fake out deaths we've had do you
think Oda would actually be bold enough
to kill off a fan favorite like law and
speaking of killing of characters here's
the most controversial one that Oda
could possibly kill at the end of the
series will Luffy die let's say that law
doesn't make the ultimate sacrifice to
make Luffy Immortal we hate to say it
but Luffy has some pretty bad death
flags for a main character first off he
wants to be the pirate king and we all
know what happened to the last pirate
king a little thing called a public
execution maybe Luffy's death will be
what sets off a brand new pirate era
secondly though just think of all the
times that it's been hinted at that
Luffy is shortening his lifespan when he
uses gear second for the first time in
this Lobby cp9 hints that such a
technique would be shortening the user's
life overall when he received his
hormonal treatments from ivankov they
also warned that it would take years of
his life and even super recently during
the fight against kaido after using gear
5 for a while Luffy appeared to
transform into an elderly man
temporarily so just how much lifespan
does Luffy really have left that he can
short and we've made it finally back to
crocomon the crazy theory that we hinted
at at the beginning of this video but
wait a minute if this is only number 8
of 11 so do you mean that there are
three more theories even wilder than
this oh yeah you should really stay
tuned for the last three but first here
is croco-mom this one is one of the most
long-running most memeified and weirdly
believable theories in the entire fan
base when Luffy helped crock dial and
code break out of imple down Emporio
iwankov convinced this former warlord to
be on his best behavior by holding some
deep dark secret over him and given that
the person who knows crocodile secret is
ivankoff who can notably change people's
genders with their hormonal Powers well
it's heavily speculated that crocodile
was actually born a woman and asked
ivankov to be turned into a man but this
fan Theory takes this speculation even
one step further it kind of suggests
that Not only was crocodile a woman
she's actually Luffy's Mother after all
Oda has stated that Luffy's mom is a
character that he's drawn repeatedly
before so really this guess is as good
as any other we have okay now for our
final three crazy theories that you
probably didn't know existed we have
theories about the one piece itself
Theory number nine is that the one piece
isn't in the grand line at all it's on
the moon now listen if this is the first
time that you hear this I promise that
this makes more sense than you think if
you're an anime only Watcher you might
not realize just how important the Moon
is actually to the story of One Piece
because in the manga itself Oda often
uses cover pages of chapters to tell
side stories about what other characters
are up to all around the world and so
after skypeia we got to see NL fulfill
his dream of traveling to the fairy
worth aka the Moon and what was and
honestly still is shocking was that the
moon was actually inhabited NL ran into
alien space pirates and an army of
automatons he even found the ruins of an
ancient civilization that would appear
to depict the winged races of the sky
islands together with images of what
looks like to be the ancient weapons so
if the moon is connected to some
mysterious ancient civilization could it
be possible that the greatest treasure
the one piece is there as well or maybe
the one piece is something else maybe
it's nothing there's no treasure at all
now this theory is practically as old as
the entire series with fans constantly
joking that the one piece would be the
adventure itself or the friends we made
along the way Oda has actually gone out
of his way to state that the one piece
is a physical treasure but knowing how
hard Oda can troll if he wants we
wouldn't put it past him for that
physical treasure to be a written note
from Roger that says the real treasure
is friendship honestly I know a few fans
who probably burn all their mongers if
that were true but the joke would be on
them because the series would already be
over but I highly doubt that Oda would
let us down instead the one-piece
treasure will probably be something
completely awesome something like the
one piece is Luffy destroying the red
line the massive continent that circles
the globe and separates the planet into
four distinct oceans oh wait why would
destroying the red line be a treasure
well this would very literally make the
world into one piece by uniting all four
oceans to one a couple of big hints for
this Theory are that marijua the capital
of the world government is located on
top of the red line if Luffy ends up
going to war against the world
government and takes the fight to them
well destroying Pangea Castle might
result in destroying the red line itself
in addition when the crew was on Fishman
Islands the fortune teller Madame
Charlie prophesies that Luffy would
destroy Fishman islands and since
Fishman Island just happens to be
located beneath the red line directly
beneath marijua that would make sense we
also have hints such as the way Lagoon
the first character we met in the grand
line repeatedly bashing his head against
the red line trying to destroy it so
Bringing Down the red line would mean
uniting the world and bringing the
people together into one people one
piece now these were really just 11 of
the wildest theories that I found after
doing tons and tons of research and I
just discussed this one about oars being
the original Joy boy that will blow your
mind as well so if you have more time go
check that one out right here